[MUSIC PLAYING]
For me and the wildlife,
with the animals that you're
going to encounter so that you
know what the behaviors are,
learning how an animal behaves,
where it's likely to be found,
or how to find them is half
of what you need to do.
The other thing is, I feel very
fortunate that I collaborate
with, usually, world
experts who have
an area of either
local knowledge,
or knowledge about
something specific
and can give even more in-depth
understanding into the animal
behavior, the location,
the currents, or what
that I'm going to anticipate,
so that I can put myself
in the right places.
But I think one of the
things that I look back
on my early life, I think it
was diving and taking pictures
because I loved it.
And learning about the
animals and their behaviors
allowed me to find
the animals first.
And not everything just
swims right in front of you,
and so obvious,
the little things
can be the most interesting.
But learning to find something
subtle is really wonderful.
And sometimes, if you can
just imagine walking down
the street, you
don't notice the way
the leaves blow the first time.
But if you walk it
over and over again,
all of a sudden the scent of the
road, the way the leaves move,
and those little rhythms
become much more interesting.
And so having a little
more familiarity
lets you get more comfortable to
get those more intimate moments
that maybe only you see, or
that a few other people who
experience it see it and
photograph [INAUDIBLE]
a photograph.
So to me, what a lot of
preparation allows for,
all while having
the understanding
that things happen
like this, and you
have to be ready to react, and
react in a moment's notice.
Especially when I'm
photographing other people,
like in Cuba, I like to talk
to them a little bit before
I make photographs
of them, mostly
because I wasn't only
there just to photograph,
but I also wanted to
learn from their stories
and learn their experiences.
And from that, it
helped inform how
I wanted to take
the image, where
I would want to take
the image, if we
wanted to include some artifacts
of theirs and such like that.
And a lot of the times, it was
also a collaboration with them
of how they wanted to be
presented in the photograph.
Like one of the photographs,
the older couple on the steps,
that's [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE]..
When I was
photographing them, he's
like, I want you to snap the
picture when I'm bringing
the bottle up to my lips.
So he's like, I want you
to show me drinking this.
And so a lot of times
it's a collaboration
with the people of
kind of bringing
their own personalities and
experiences within the image
rather than either projecting
my view or my ideology,
I guess, on them, and
having a little bit more
of their voice within the image.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, I'm trying to document
a lot of natural behavior,
so I would like to have
as little direct impact
on the animals.
In the underwater world,
what's really amazing is
they have to want to come close.
And it's a big ocean
out there, and they
can swim away quite easily.
So in order to do
this, there has
to be some sort of little
momentary connection
between the animal and myself,
to be able to get to a range
where I can actually make a
picture that's reasonable.
And so it's a wonderful
sort of feeling
to learn how to move your
body, to interact in a place
to be a silent observer, but
also to be someone that can be
in a position to actually
capture something that's
occurring, a feeding behavior,
a mating kind of thing,
a curious whale that wants
to swim up to you that
is interested in
something, a shark that
is interested in sort
of moving around you.
And so those moments are natural
and happen on their own way.
But getting in the right
place or positioning
oneself for those
to happen is really
an art form in and of
itself and something
I also spent a fair
amount of time working on,
is how to be in the right
place at the right time.
And you always want
to be in two places,
and you're never
in the right place,
nor do I ever have
the right lens
and all that kind of stuff.
And so they're all
a million reasons
why things don't work out.
But every now and
then, you have success,
and it feels really wonderful.
I'm definitely trying to
engage in the environments
that I'm photographing,
mostly because I want
to create those relationships.
But also having the
camera that I have,
walking around a lot of
these small towns in Cuba,
a lot of times we would
hear chatter of people.
Like I would be known
in that little town,
I'd be this person
walking around
with this big contraption thing.
Yeah, when I want to
photograph, I definitely
want to connect as much
as I can with the people
and create a relationship.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's really the power
of observation for me
that is what's so interesting.
And I really enjoy that moment.
And I enjoy it not just with
the camera to take a picture,
I enjoy the power of
actually learning to look
and watching
something for a while.
And I find that to be one of
the most enjoyable experiences
to just sort of sit and look.
Even when I'm not
photographing, I
keep on observing, trying to
find the little details that
really make a scene and
make almost mental images
in my mind of
inspiration of possibly
making that image later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In terms of tips
for people, I think
one thing is to pick something
that is easily accessible.
So in my case, I like wildlife.
So if we were
thinking of animals,
I might pick animals
that are local.
If it's a robin that
has a nest right
in your yard, a squirrel,
a cat, something
that you're comfortable with.
And think of what
do you want to say
about that animal or that plant?
Or what would you
like it to look like?
And what time of day are
you photographing this?
Instead of having things be
arbitrary, pause for a moment
and think, what do you
want the image to say?
What would you like to tell
someone about that plant?
Why do you like that flower that
stopped and took that picture?
And then begin to
think about, what
are the shape, the form,
the color, the time?
And what is it that you really
like about it that caused you
to pause in that way?
And I think, as you begin
to question yourself
of what you want
to say about it,
I would encourage you to
then take a few other images
and say, well, how
can I enhance what
it is I would like
to convey about it?
Do I want to be
close to this image?
Do I want to be far from it?
Do I want to be looking down?
Do I want to be looking up?
And I think those
are the elements
that you begin to have.
And so instead of it just,
oh, I snapped this picture
and I really liked
it, to notice them,
and to really begin to
sort of ask yourself
what you want to say about it.
With photography, think
about a topic or an emotion
or something that
you're deeply involved
with or passionate about, or
that you find yourself wanting
to express or talk about.
And then think of the ways
that you can showcase that
within photography.
And I would just end
on one quick thing.
Golfing is easy.
Bike riding is easy.
But these people practice
over and over again.
And no one believes me, but
it's a skill to do this stuff,
and you have to practice
this over and over again.
And I love doing
this photography,
and I'm sure Caterina
does as well.
And so it's something you
do over and over again.
And so it's not just that
I walk up to something,
and I get one time lucky on
this, although maybe that does
happen.
These are skills that I'm
working on constantly,
on getting myself ready
so the reflex is boom,
I'm right here with the
camera, and I'm ready for it.
Boom, my lights are
right where I want them.
I'm thinking.
I'm very aware of these things.
And I think that that
practice is really
critically important in
the art of photography
and storytelling, at
whatever subject you're
interested in photographing.
So my number one tip is find
the subject that you like,
photograph it, and think about
what you want to say about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]